ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะคือเลี้ยงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนะคะ En หน้าสวัสดี
ค่ะวันนี้กลับมาพบกับคุณฟ้าแล้วก็ครู
เรียมในวีดีโอบีกินเนอร์ 4 นะคะมีกินๆชอบ
ทอมเปลี่ยนสีเบอร์ไทยค่ะช่องคอมเม้นต์
silver ไทยใช่แล้วค่ะ
นี่ก็เราไปเจอกันถ้วนอะไรคะวันนี้วันนี้
วันพุธค่ะโคเรียมวันพุธใช่ไหม
วันพุธโอเควันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ติดมา
เนื่องเดือนอะไรคะภูฟ้าเดือน
สิงหาคม
ปีพศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
แล้วปีคศอะไรคะ
2022 ค่ะ
นี้กี่โมงนะคะครูป๊าตอนนี้เวลา 14:00 นง
43 นาทีน 14:00 น 43
น.ใช้เวลาต่อจากคลิปที่แล้วแล้วเวลาต่อ
สกี้แล้วเลยนะคะนักเรียนจะได้ออกกันน่ะสิ
เขาว่าแบบเดี๋ยวกำลังรออยู่เลยว่าแบบจาก
ที่เราฟังเจ้าชาย 12 ในคลิปที่แล้ว
เจ้าชายทั้งสิบสองออกไปข้างนอกวางใช่ไหม
หนีเข้าป่าหน้าใช่มีเข้าไปในป่าและตอนนี้
เจ้าหญิงก็รู้แล้วนะคะว่าเจ้าหญิงมีพี่
ชาย 12 คนเจ้าหญิงก็เลยไปตามหาว่าพี่ชาย
ในอยู่ที่ไหน
จังหวัดไม่ได้ดูล่ะพี่ที่ให้ยังไม่ได้ดู
หรอกก็ต้องไปดูวีดีโอที่แล้วก่อนนะคะนัก
เรียนว่านี่เป็น part  two นะนิเคราะห์
ชื่ออะไรอะที่ 2 มีของใช่ใครที่ดูมาแล้ว
ก็มาค่ะมาดูกันต่อว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นเจ้า
หญิงงานหากเข้าไปในป่า
และข้ออะไรบ้างเนี่ยเกาะเดินไปเรื่อยๆค่ะ
โคเรียมเดินแล้วก็หาว่าในป่าจะมีผู้ชาย 12
คนไหม
ผู้ชาย 12 คนเนี่ยนะจะเห็นง่ายๆหรอได้ก็
เจ้าหญิงก็เดินไปจนเมื่อไหร่ละ
เจ้าหญิงไปคนเดียวเลยหรอคะครูป๊าคนเดียว
ค่ะโคเรียมเจ้าหญิงไปคนเดียวเราไม่มีคุณ
แม่ไม่มีคุณพ่อไม่มีเพื่อนไม่มีใครไปคน
เดียวโอโหแม่เขาแบบแม่เขาไม่เป็นห่วงหรอ
บอกแบบให้คนตามไปแบบสั้น 1 คน 2 คนอะไร
เงี้ยที่ว่าน่าจะไม่เป็นห่วงนะมาเจาะไม่
ห่วงเลยเด็ก 10 ขวบใช่ป่ะผม
ซึ่งสิบขวบ 10 ฮวกใช่หาเจ้าหญิงก็เดินจน
ไปเจอบ้านหลังเล็กๆหลังหนึ่งบ้านเล็กๆ
หลังบ้านเล็กๆ
ใช่ไหมใช่หรือเปล่าผู้หญิงก็เดินเข้าไปใน
บ้านแล้วก็เจอเด็กผู้ชายคนนึง
เด็กผู้ชายคนนั้นก็ถามเจ้าหญิงว่า
เธอเป็นใคร
เธอเป็นใครมาทำอะไรที่นี่
เอาให้เขาใช่เจ้าชายหรือเปล่านั่นน่ะสิ
ว่าถ้าเกิดเป็นชายเขาต้องฆ่าแล้วนะคะถ้า
ผู้หญิงไม่ใช่เหรอคือผู้ชายคนนี้ได้เขา
กำลัง
เห็นเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยเจ้าหญิงสวยใช่ไหมก็เลย
เหมือนว่า
ตะลึงนะคะอรุณก็คือแบบหูผู้หญิงสวยจัง
และเจ้าหญิงอยากจะบอกว่าฉันเป็นเจ้าหญิง
มีมึงมีนี่นะมีมงกุฎด้วยนะเป็นเจ้าหญิง
ฉันกำลังมาหาพี่ชาย 12 คนแล้วจะเห็นก็
หยิบเสื้อเชิ้ตออกมานะคะว่ามีเสื้อ 12
ตัวอือผู้ชายคนนั้นเนี่ยจริงๆก็คือ
เบญจมินทร์พี่ชายของเจ้าหญิงนั่นแหละ
เบญจมินทร์พอได้ยินก็เลยแบบฉันเป็นพี่ชาย
ของเธอเนอะแล้วเบญจมินทร์ก็เข้าไปก่อน
เจ้าหญิงนะคะอ้าวไอ้เขากับสัญญากันไงคิด
ว่าเป็นคนหน้าผู้หญิงเป็นจะบินน่าจะเป็น
คนที่
ไม่อาจจะเป็นคนใจดีอ่ะคิดว่านะน่าจะดูไง
ดีสวยมากหวยเห็นแล้วก็เราบอกว่า
ผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็คือน้องสาวใช่ไหม
เบญจมินทร์ก็ร้องไห้นะคะเจ้าหญิงก็ร้อง
ไห้และ 2 คนแต่กอดกันคือข้างเบญจมินทร์ก็
บอกว่า
พี่ดีใจมากๆเลยที่ได้เจอน้องแต่ว่าน้อง
เนี่ยจะต้องไปแอบก่อน
แอบแพงไงนะเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดพี่ชายคนอื่น
เห็นผู้หญิงเนี่ยเขาก็จะฆ่าใช่ไหม
เบญจมินทร์ก็เลยให้น้องสาวอย่าไปแอบหยุด
นะคะพอดีว่าพี่ชาย 11 คนก็กลับมาที่บ้าน
พอดีแล้วทุกคนก็กินข้าวก็นั่งกินข้าวด้วย
กัน
เบญจมินทร์ก็บอกว่าวันนี้เนี่ยฉันมี
เรื่องจะเล่าให้ฟัง
พี่ชายบอกว่าเรื่องอะไรมีเรื่องอะไรมี
เรื่องอะไรอัพเดทหรอไม่ต้องอัพเดท Update
กันไหมมึงก็พิมพ์ก็บอกว่าอยากรู้ไหม
พี่ชาย
เนี่ยเตรียมอยากรู้เออเล่นฉันก็เลยบอกว่า
ถ้าอย่างนั้นก็ต้องอ่าสัญญามาสัญญาเนาะ
สัญญานะคะว่า
ห้ามฆ่าผู้หญิงนะท่านคือผู้หญิงห้ามฆ่านะ
โอเคไหม
พี่ชายก็แปลว่าไอ้ทำไมล่ะทำไมข้าวอยู่ไหน
ได้แต่ว่าพี่ชายก็โอเคพี่ชาย 11 คนก็บอก
ว่าได้สัญญาสาบานสัญญาเลยว่าจะไม่ฆ่าผู้
หญิง
เบญจมินก็เลยพาน้องสาวพาเจ้าหญิงน่ะออกมา
แล้วก็บอกว่านี่คือน้องสาวของเรา
พี่ชายอีก 11 คนเห็นน้องสาวก็เลยค่าหวย
ไหมค่านักเรียนเพราะว่าน้องสาวเนี่ยสวย
น่ารักไงเราบอกว่าเด็กๆผู้หญิงอ่ะพี่ชาย
รู้สึกว่าน้องสาวแล้วก็รักน้องฝากเดิน
เข้ามาก่อนเขาเกลียดผู้หญิงทุกคนเพราะว่า
น้องสาวเขานะใช่ก็ฆ่าผู้หญิงหาก็เยอะเรา
ไหมแต่พอเห็นน้องสาวไหมค่านะไม่ฆ่าน้อง
สาวดูแล้วว่าความสวยที่นอนจริงๆ
อาจจะเป็นสติเพิ่มก่อนใครจะฆ่าเขาเนี้ย
เอาใจเราจะได้ไม่ตายไงถ้าเกิดแบบอยู่ดีๆ
ว่า
ถ้าเกิดแบบสวยๆใช่หาไม่ตายได้ก็ไม่ต้อง
กัดดีนะใช่แล้วค่ะนั่นแหละเราก็จะเป็น
เพราะว่าเป็นพี่น้องกันก็เลยรักกันนะคะ
พี่ชายก็โอเคกอดกับน้องสาวแล้วก็ทั้ง 13
คนเนี่ยก็กดลงว่าจะอยู่ด้วยกันที่บ้านโดย
ที่เบญจมินทร์กับเจ้าหญิงแม่ก็จะช่วยกัน
ทำความสะอาดม่านกวาดถูว่านใช่ไหมช่วยกัน
ทำความสะอาดและพี่ชาย 11 คนเนี่ยก็จะออก
ไปหาสนานออกไปหาหมูหาไก่นกมาเป็นอาหารนะ
คะแต่ทุกคนก็อยู่ด้วยกันอย่างมีความสุข
เย้
ยังไม่จบค่ะครูเรียม
ยังมีอีกอะไรอีกหรือว่าฮัลโหลอะไรนะเขา
กลับไปที่วางหรอคะไม่ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ามี
อยู่ 1 วันเจ้าหญิงในก็ออกไปเดินเล่นใช่
ไหมออกไปเดินเดินเดินแล้วก็ไปเห็นดอกไม้
ค่ะโคเรียม
ดอกไม้เนี่ยเป็นดอกพลับพลึงอ่ะ
เหมือนเดิมเห็นอยู่เห็นดอกคำพึงแถวนี้หาย
ไปไหนละทรัพย์ซื้อเป็นดอกไม้ที่สวยตัวของ
เจ้าหญิงเนี่ยนี่เลยเห็นไหมไม่ต้องไปสวย
จัง
สอบทัพเรือหนึ่งชายห่าพอเจ้าหญิงเห็นดอก
พลับพลึงเดี๋ยวเจ้าหญิงก็เลยตัด
จะเอาไปให้พี่ชายเพราะว่าดอกไม้สวยคิดว่า
เอาไปให้พี่ชายละกันก็ตัดดอกพลับพลึงมา 12
ดอก
หมอเขาเจ้าหญิงตัดดอกทับเชิงแล้วเนี่ย
เจ้าชายอ่ะตอนแรกเจ้าชายเป็นคนนะคะแต่โฮ
เจ้าหญิงตัดดอกไม้เจ้าชายก็กลายเป็นนก
เป็นอีกาค่ะโคเรียมเป็นอีกาอีกาก็คือแบบ
น้องกดดำดำๆน่าใช่ฮะอีกาคืนอย่างเงี้ยอา
ใช้แล้วเหมือนไหมล่ะทีเนี้ย
ได้อยู่นะ
โอเคอยู่นะเออเพื่อนนกสีดำๆอ่ะอีดำ 1 สี
ดำนะเราเลขอีกาผู้ชายก็กลายเป็นอีกาผู้
หญิงก็ตกใจมากว่าทำไมต้องชายถึงกลายเป็น
อีกาล่ะ
อ้ารถทำยังไงเค้ารู้ได้ยังไงว่าเจ้าชาย
กลายเป็นอีกาคืออีกาพูดได้หรอแล้วเขาบอก
ไม่ได้ค่ะแต่ว่าระหว่างที่เจ้าหญิงกำลัง
ช็อกสี
ชอล์คอยู่น้ำก็มีผู้หญิงคนหนึ่งเดินเข้า
มาบอกเจ้าหญิงว่า
เจ้าหญิงทำแบบนี้ไม่ได้นะเพราะว่าที่บ้าน
หลังเนี่ยมันมีเวทมนตร์
ใช่คือถ้าเจ้าหญิงตัดดอกไม้ไปเนี่ยเจ้า
ชายก็จะกลายเป็นอีกา
แม่รถ
ผู้หญิงฟังมาตั้งนานก็ไม่คิดว่าบ้านเนี่ย
จะมีแบบเวทมนตร์ใช่ไหมฟังมาตั้งนานนะคะก็
คิดว่าบ้านธรรมดาจะไม่หาบ้านมีเวทมนตร์
ไม่คือแบบว่ามีอะไรที่มันก็เคยใช่ไหมใช่
เวทมนตร์นะคะผู้หญิงก็ร้องไห้แล้วก็ถาม
ว่าทำยังไงจะช่วยพี่ชายได้ยังไง
ผู้หญิงคนนั้นก็บอกว่าเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยช่วย
พี่ชายได้นะแต่
การช่วยพี่ชายในก็คือผู้หญิงก็ต้องห้าม
พูด
ห้ามพูดห้ามหัวเราะ
หัวเราะอีกยังไม่ได้
ห้ามห้ามห้ามอย่างนี้ก็ได้อ่ะสิอะ
อันเนี้ยได้ไหมไม่ได้ห่างไม่ได้ห้ามพูด
เลย
100% เป็นเวลา 7 ปีค่ะครูเรียนปิดโอ้ย
แต่ก็แต่ก็โอเคนะเพราะไม่ได้เจอใครไงก็
ไม่อยู่ในป่าไหมเจ้าหญิงก็เลยโอเคเจ้า
หญิงจะช่วยพี่ชายให้ได้ก็เลยปีนขึ้นไปบน
ต้นไม้และก็เหมือนนั่งอยู่บนต้นไม้ไม่คุย
กับใครไม่พูด
เวลาผ่านไปนะคะก็มีพระราชาคนหนึ่งที่ไม่
ใช่พ่อของเจ้าหญิงนะไม่ใช่พ่อของเจ้าหญิง
เจ้าชายก็คิดว่าพระราชาเนี่ยก็ขี่ม้ามา
จากเมืองอื่นใช่ไหมมาจากเมืองอื่นนะคะที่
มาว่าซึ่งช้านี้ชอบขี่มานะมาชอบกี่โมงชาย
พระราชาก็มาที่ในป่าแล้วก็เหมือนกำลังที่
จะ
ดูวิวหรือเปล่าแต่เห็นเจ้าหญิงนั่งอยู่บน
ต้นไม้พระราชาก็คิดทำไมผู้หญิงคนนี้สวย
จัง
มากว้าว
ก็เลยคุยกับเจ้าหญิงแล้วก็บอกว่าฉันอยาก
แต่งงานกับเธอฉันชอบเธอเธอโอเคไหม
ตัวของผู้หญิงเนี่ยพูดไม่ได้ใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงก็เลย
พยักหน้านะคะเอ้าพยักหน้านึกว่าเธอหญิง
แต่แบบ
ผู้หญิงแต่งงานดีกว่าจะยิ่งเหงาและอยู่คน
เดียวนะคะก็เลยแต่งงานแล้วก็ไปที่มันจะ
ไม่พูดด้วยเจ้าชายก็คิดอ๋อก็หญิงน่าจะพูด
ไม่ได้เฮ้อก็เลยพาเจ้าหญิงเนี่ยไปอยู่ใน
วังด้วยกันแต่ผู้หญิงก็ไม่พูดไม่พูดไม่
หัวเราะ
เงียบ
ทำให้แม่ของพระราชาไม่ใช่ชายเราก็พูดผิด
แม่ของพระราชาเนี่ยรู้สึกว่าไม่ชอบไม่ชอบ
เจ้าหญิงนี่แม่ของพระราชาก็เลยบอกพระราชา
ว่าผู้หญิงคนนี้เนี่ยเป็นผู้หญิงไม่ดี
อ้าวรู้ได้ยังไงแค่เขาพูดไม่ได้เพราะว่า
แม่บอกว่าพูดไม่ได้เนี่ยโอเคแต่ไม่
หัวเราะฮ่าๆๆไม่หัวเราะเลยไม่ยิ้ม
แปลว่าต้องเป็นคนไม่ดีแน่เลยหล่อเล่นคิด
ว่าแบบแค่เขาแบบถ้าเกิดไม่ยิ้มก็ก็แปลว่า
ไม่มีความสุขไงก็แปลว่ามีความสุขหรือ
เปล่าแม่ของพระราชาในก็พูดทุกวันพระราชา
เจ้าหญิงหน้าเป็นคนไม่ดีนะ
พูดพูดๆทุกวันตอนแรกเนี่ยพระราชาก็ไม่
เชื่อว่ารักเจ้าหญิงใช่ไหม
แต่พ่อแม่พูดทุกวันเนี่ยพระราชาก็เลยเลย
เนาะแต่เจ้าหญิงก็ไม่เคยพูดไม่เคยหัวเราะ
เป็นคนไม่ดีหรือเปลือกผู้หญิงยิ้มบ้างไหม
แบบไม่ยิ้มเลยค่ะ
เรียนก็แบบรู้สึกแปลกๆนะถ้าเกิดอยู่กับคน
ที่แบบไม่พูดไม่ไม่ยิ้ม
หัวเราะพวกค้าจะรู้สึกยังไงที่แบบ
ขอ Love เขาทำได้ยังไงเท่าดูมิสเตอร์บีน
ก็จะขำไหมแล้วก็นั้นก็ได้นะคะว่าเราไปดู
หนังตลกเนี่ยก็จะหัวเราะแต่ผู้หญิงไม่
หัวเราะเลยค่ะจิงมากๆผมเชื่อคุณแม่พระ
ราชาสิ่งที่กษาปณ์พระราชาก็เลยเชื่อคุณ
แม่คะแล้วก็เลยบอกว่า
ถ้าเจ้าหญิงเป็นคนไม่ดีเราก็ต้องฆ่าเจ้า
หญิงอ้าเอา
เจ้าชายเอ่อพระราชาพระราชาแค่แบบไล่เขาไป
ก็พอจะไปข้างเขาทำไม
ว่าช้าก็เลยเตรียมเลยค่ะเอาตัวเจ้าหญิงไป
แล้วก็มีไฟเนาะบอกว่าเป็นการเผา
นักเรียนเอามีดกับค่าก็โอเคแล้วนะอัน
นี้แต่แบบใช้ไฟเผาเลยหรอให้ไฟเผาขนมก็
ต้องหารูปกันว่ามีไหม
เขาเลยนะเผาก็คืนป๋าให้นักเรียนไปน้อยใน
แล้วก็มีเจ้าหญิงทำไมอ่ะพระราชทานรักไม่
ใช่หรอฤารักว่าเจ้าหญิงไม่ใช่เอาทำไมต้อง
มาเปาแบบเป็นเขาใฝ่อาจจะแบบคุณแม่ไงคุณ
แม่พูดก็เชื่อคุณแม่อย่างเงี้ยพระราชาก็
ร้องไห้มากๆนะคะตอนที่เจ้าหญิงถูกพาไป
เนี่ยร้องไห้ร้องไห้แต่ว่าทำอะไรไม่ได้
เพราะว่าอาจจะมีคุณแม่แล้วก็มีคนอื่นๆพูด
เนี่ยมันก็ต้องเชื่อแบบเป็นผู้หญิงไม่ดี
เป็นผู้หญิงไม่ดีเจ้าหญิงในก็ไม่พูดไม่
ยอมพูดเลยจนโดนไฟเผาในก็ยังไม่พูดอยู่ไม่
เผาด้วยหรอใช่หาคิดว่าจะนั่งอยู่บนอะไร
สักอย่างหรือเปล่าแล้วก็คือไฟก็เริ่มไปไฟ
ๆน่าจะนั่งแบบเหมือนแบบอยู่บนไม้แบบนี้
คือตั้งอยู่บนไม้
ใช่ๆเยอะๆ
เราก็มีไฟอยู่ข้างล่างใช่หาอย่างงั้นเรา
จะหญิงก็นั่งอยู่หน้าแล้วก็ไฟก็เริ่มกับ
ลูกขึ้นเยอะๆๆมีแต่ว่าพอดีว่าวันนี้เนี่ย
เป็นวันที่ครบ 7 ปีที่เจ้าหญิงไม่พูดแล้ว
ไม่หัวเราะเลยทำให้อีกาที่ดินอยู่ 12 ตัว
เนี่ยกลับมาเป็นเจ้าชายเหมือนเดิม
แล้วจะชาย 12 คนก็เลยรีบวิ่งมาช่วยเจ้า
หญิงนะคะก็คือเอาเจ้าหญิงออกมาจากไฟแล้ว
ก็ช่วยมาได้เจ้าชายก็ร้องไห้เจ้าหญิงก็
เลยร้องไห้แล้วก็กอดกันเพราะว่าเจ้าหญิง
ทำได้แล้วช่วยชีวิตพี่ชาย 12 คนได้แล้ว
แล้วก็เลยเล่าให้พระราชาฟังเล่าให้ฟังนะ
ว่าทำไมเจ้าหญิงถึงไม่พูดทำไมถึงไม่
หัวเราะเพราะว่าเจ้าหญิงไม่อยากช่วยพี่
ชายหื่นเจ้าชายก็ดีใจมากที่ไม่ต้องฆ่า
เจ้าหญิงแล้วนะคะก็เลยให้เจ้าหญิงแม่มา
อยู่ในวางด้วยกันแล้วก็ให้พี่ชายอีกอยู่ 2
คนเนี่ยมาอยู่ด้วยกันทั้งหมดเลยและทุกคน
ก็อยู่ด้วยกันอย่างมีความสุขค่ะกริยามาก
ลืมก็เล่นนึกขึ้นได้ว่าแล้วพระราชาอีก
เมืองนึงอ่ะที่เป็นกับพระราชินีที่เป็น
พ่อกับแม่ของเจ้าชายทั้ง 12 คนแล้วก็เจ้า
หญิงอีกคนนึงเนี่ยที่มีลูก 13 คนแต่ว่า
ลูกทั้ง 13 คนอ่ะไม่ได้อยู่ในวางเลยหนี
ออกมากันหมดเลย New มาเลยพ่อแม่ก็อยู่
ด้วยกันไป 2 คนนะลูกนี้มาหมดแล้วหรือว่า
เขาจะมีลูกอีกก็ได้หรอก็จะมีรูปอีกก็ได้
แล้วก็ไม่รู้ไงใช่มั้ยน้องแต่ละก็แบบ
เดี๋ยวไปอยู่เลยนะพ่อคิดจะฆ่า
พ่อก็ได้จะไม่โอเคไงลูกก็เลยมียกมาหมดเลย
นะคะแล้วก็เลยไปอยู่ด้วยกันที่เมืองอีก
เมืองนึงเนาะมาจะมีหลายๆเมืองแล้วมาก่อน
อ.เมืองเมืองเมืองแล้วก็จะมีพระราชาพระ
ราชาพระราชาในหลายคนยังไง
ชายชายทุกคนก็เลยอยู่ด้วยกันอย่างมีความ
สุขอันนี้เลยเป็นนิทานที่จบดีนะคะก็ดีใจ
ล่ะที่จบโอเค Happy  Ending นี่นะใช่ค่ะ
นิทานเรื่องนี้ก็ไม่ได้มีใครตายนอกจากผู้
หญิงคนอื่นที่ไม่เกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้เลย
ว่าพี่ชายฆ่าทิ้งนะพี่ชายไปฆ่าผู้หญิงคน
อื่นแต่ไม่ฆ่าน้องสาวตัวเองให้จะเป็นพี่
น้องกันเห็นไหมเห็นประโยชน์จากเรื่องนี้
ไหมว่าคนเราเนี่ยความสวยความสวยเนี่ยเป็น
สิ่งที่สำคัญมากซึ่งส่วนนั้นสิ่งที่สำคัญ
หารอต้องสวย
นั่นแหละอันนี้ก็เลยเป็นเรื่องเป็น Story
นะคะนิทานที่ฟ้าเอามาเล่าให้ฟังอีกทีก็
เราก็มีนิทานอีกมีหลายเรื่องเลยนะคะนัก
เรียนมีอีกหลาย Sorry เลยเรียนอยากฟัง
อะไรมันก็บอกได้นะคะตอบนั้นมาด้านล่างก็
ได้ไม่ได้เลยค่ะนักเรียนใช่แล้วก็ได้อัน
นี้ครูฟ้ากับโคเรียมโบราหรือยังคะเนี่ย
เคยหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะคือฟ้าได้ทั้งหมดเวลา
แล้วเราสองคนอาจจะต้องไปก่อนนะคะนักเรียน
เหนื่อยค่ะเดี๋ยวเจอกันในคลิปหน้าวีดีโอ
หน้าว่าหลายใช่ดูว่าเราจะมีอะไรมันเล่า
ให้นักเรียนฟังบ้างนะคะได้เลยเขาที่ถ้า
เกิดชอบผิดนี้ทำไงคะครูป้าอ่อนอย่าลืมกด
like กด Share กด Subscribe ด้วยนะคะนัก
เรียนได้หาเราก็กดอะไรอ่ะเอานี่กำลังสั่น
กระดิ่งอ่ะเศร้าสุดท้ายอันนี้จะเป็น
กระดิ่งแจ้งเตือนหรออ๋ออ๋อกระดิ่งมันจะมี
แจ้งเตือนนะคะเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดมีวีดีโอ
ใหม่ๆนักเรียนก็จะเอามีวีดีโอมาแล้ว
ได้ค่ะจะได้รู้วันนี้ต้องลาไปร้านจริงๆ
ค่ะลูกฟ้าก็ได้ค่ะคุณเรียนไม่เจอกันใหม่
นะคะนั่งเรียนไว้บายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ